A total lunar eclipse is about to make the moon appear a reddish color across the Western Hemisphere.
一场月全食即将使西半球的月亮呈现红色。
The event will happen Thursday night into Friday morning.
这一事件将在周四晚至周五早上发生。
The best places to see the eclipse will be in North America and South America.
观赏月食的最佳地点将是北美洲和南美洲。
Parts of Africa and Europe may also get brief views.
非洲和欧洲部分地区也可能短暂看到。
A lunar eclipse happens when the sun, Earth, and moon line up just right, with Earth positioned between the sun and moon.
当太阳、地球和月球完美排列，地球位于太阳和月球之间时，就会发生月食。
This causes the Earth to create a shadow on the moon.
这导致地球在月球上投下阴影。
In a total lunar eclipse, the Earth's shadow covers all of the moon.
在月全食中，地球的阴影覆盖了整个月球。
Another kind of eclipse is a solar eclipse.
另一种食是日食。
In a solar eclipse, the moon gets in a position where it blocks light from the sun, causing a partial or full shadow on Earth.
在日食中，月球处于阻挡太阳光的位置，导致地球出现部分或全部阴影。
A total lunar eclipse can also be called a blood moon.
月全食也可以被称为血月。
It makes the moon appear reddish-orange, similar to the element copper.
它使月亮呈现红橙色，类似于铜元素。
The color comes from small amounts of sunlight passing through the Earth's atmosphere.
这种颜色来自于少量阳光穿过地球大气层。
The American space agency NASA says lunar and solar eclipses happen between four and seven times a year.
美国航天局NASA表示，月食和日食每年发生四到七次。
The last total lunar eclipse was in 2022.
上一次月全食发生在2022年。
This one will be visible for about one hour starting Friday morning at 2:26 a.m. Eastern Daylight Time (EDT).
这次月全食将在周五凌晨2点26分（美国东部夏令时间）开始，持续约一小时。
The time when the Earth's shadow covers all of the moon will be close to 3 a.m. EDT.
地球阴影完全覆盖月球的时刻将接近美国东部夏令时间凌晨3点。
"As long as the sky is clear, you should be able to see it," Shannon Schmoll told the Associated Press.
“只要天空晴朗，你应该能看到它，”香农·施莫尔告诉美联社。
She is the director of Abrams Planetarium at Michigan State University.
她是密歇根州立大学艾布拉姆斯天文馆的馆长。
No special equipment will be needed to see the reddish moon.
观看红色的月亮不需要特殊设备。
The total lunar eclipse may be harder to see in Europe and Africa because the moon will be close to setting.
由于月亮即将落下，欧洲和非洲可能更难看到月全食。
Michael Faison is an astronomy expert from Yale University.
迈克尔·费森是耶鲁大学的天文学专家。
He told the AP, "This is really an eclipse for North and South America."
他告诉美联社：“这确实是北美洲和南美洲的月食。”
Zoe Ortiz is a historian with the University of North Texas.
佐伊·奥尔蒂斯是北德克萨斯大学的历史学家。
She noted that different civilizations have observed lunar eclipses for thousands of years.
她指出，不同文明已经观测月食数千年了。
This helped ancient people learn things about the behaviors of the sun, moon, and stars.
这帮助古人了解了太阳、月球和恒星的行为。
"They were looking at the night sky and they had a much brighter vision than we do today," Ortiz said.
“他们仰望夜空，看到的景象比我们今天要明亮得多，”奥尔蒂斯说。
The ancient Greek thinker and writer Aristotle observed that Earths' shadow on the moon during a lunar eclipse was always curved.
古希腊思想家、作家亚里士多德观察到，月食期间地球在月球上的阴影总是弯曲的。
This fact supported proof that the Earth is round.
这一事实支持了地球是球形的证据。
The next total lunar eclipse will appear in the sky September 7, across parts of Asia, Africa, Australia and Europe.
下一次月全食将于9月7日出现在天空，覆盖亚洲、非洲、澳大利亚和欧洲部分地区。
Parts of the Americas will get the next chance to see one in March 2026.
美洲部分地区将在2026年3月获得下一次观测机会。
I'm Caty Weaver.
我是凯蒂·韦弗。